the world out there is marked by
survival
by a kind or refuses to die shouldn't we
to try to survive
[Music]
truth is we don't all deserve to make
[Music]
hey guys Pete here are you watching
Westworld and wondering what's gonna
come up next week well this will be a
trailer breakdown for episode 3 of bless
world season 2 they're actually calling
it a teaser what we have here last week
we had in the coming weeks which had a
trailer with stuff that was in this
episode and will be in future episodes
feel like most of what we just saw will
actually be in the episode coming up
this week Game of Thrones did that a
little bit last season so hopefully
we'll fall into a regular trailer
routine as the season progresses the
teaser is called survival but the
episode is actually titled virtue a
Fortuna which translates rather simply
into virtue and fortune let's break this
down scene by scene there's not a whole
lot here and then let's discuss what we
think is gonna happen next week so the
trailer opens with a shot of a train
tunnel you can see a plume of smoke it
makes it look like a train has just gone
through or just entered I guess you
would say feel like there has been some
foreshadowing related to this canyon
scenery of course the train tunnels
going through the canyon wall at the end
of the last episode we got some ideas
that Dolores and Bill the man in black
are going to the same place something
that he showed her in the past I don't
think we have anything that says this is
exactly what that is but we did see the
canyon being built and we saw that shot
of the canyon several times the
voiceover is pretty short and sweet
Dolores says the world out there is
marked by survival by a kind that
refuses to die
shouldn't we to try to survive and she
says that to Bernard the truth is we
don't all deserve to make it after the
tunnel scene we see Delos employees with
machine guns going across what looks
like a battlefield it see that it's been
fortified with like some wooden spikes
so there should be defenders waiting for
these guys to arrive see smoke in the
air and then we see another shot of the
super cool dune buggies that they drive
around and that lets us know this is
probably in the lead-up to when we saw
them arrive on the beach the next shot
is a bit mysterious I've been looking at
it and I can't really make out exactly
what's going on you can see a host is
walking away in front of these other
hosts who are all have guns drawn and
are getting ready to shoot at something
but we do see here is the evolution of
the hosts who look like the Wyatt guys
that we saw on the very first trailer
you can see that they're banded together
what they're shooting at I have no idea
it cuts to a shot of Angela but that is
unrelated as far as you can tell by the
location my first guess was this line of
guys shooting was in Sweetwater but it
could really be anywhere in the park
there's nothing that totally gives it
away as to what or where they're at as
mentioned we do see the crown of thorns
wearing Angela was a long gun she [ __ ]
it and gives it a shot we can see that
Dolores is behind her in this
it looks like it's out on the Prairie
and Dolores has some blood that you can
see on her shoulder in this actual shot
as far as timing goes it's really kind
of difficult at this point to put things
together we know all of this goes down
in between when Ford dies and when Delos
arrives on the beach but we're gonna
have to have a lot more in order to
stitch the timing together after that we
do have the scene where Dolores is
talking to Bernhard and she's talking
about they should try to survive when I
first saw this I thought maybe that it
looked like Bernard was not active like
he was turned off but when you watch it
a few times you can see that it looks
like he blinks so he is listening to her
when and how these two come together
we'll have to wait and see there's more
I want to talk about this but I'll talk
about it a little bit later and in my
episode to recap and review which I'll
do after this video see a quick glimpse
of a guy falling to the ground looks
like a host is he being run down by
Dolores is he being run down by Delos or
is he being run down by the ghost nation
there's no way to tell from this clip
from there
see the ghost nation we see them coming
in and of course there is some
connection to that from the first
episode where we saw that Delores told
the member of ghost nation that not all
of them get to go to the valley beyond
we did get one of the actors that was
cast in episode 2 found out that he's a
very old host as old as Dolores and
Angela and I don't think it'd be
surprising at all if he figures into the
ghost nation's storyline post Ford's
death now of course I say Ford's death
because I think they pretty much closed
the door on that in episode 1 whenever
they showed his body decomposing that's
not a host there's maggots eating the
flesh but at the same time it seems like
all of what we're seeing and what we're
about to see and the rest of the season
has all been orchestrated by him before
he was taken out after the ghost nation
we get a shot of Hector who looks
excited about something I don't know if
excited is the exact word I'm looking
for but he's interested in what's
happening we see the light sort of flash
and get brighter but not much more there
to understand what's happening there it
could be made behind him it's most
likely made behind him but you can't
tell for sure and then we get a glance
of the del O's employees coming across
the field we see those wooden spikes
again and we see what I guess is
Confederate oohs I'm not sure but they
do have numbers and this is looks like
an organized defense the dillos
employees obviously have a advantage
with their firearms they have like
machine guns compared to the regular
long guns and the other side but the
fact that they're just walking across
the field here kind of tells me that
they were surprised to run into this
situation like they won't I wouldn't
think they would advance standing up
against a line of enemies if they
thought they were going to just get
gunned down so we'll see what's going on
with that after that we see Mae looking
up at what looks to be snow probably
moving from one world to the other
although we know now that even though
she's probably going to show gun were
in Episode five based on the titles her
child the one that she's looking for
actually is not in Shogun world so
that's cool to give us something to
ponder as to why they actually go there
let me see Dolores walking across an
open space that's the best thing I could
think of to call it she's got her gun
drawn and taking shots and she takes a
shot literally biked and she gets hit in
the waist that she's going this looks
like a single shot from a handgun
similar to what she's holding I would
guess not something that the machine gun
guys have who she's walking up on here
really no way to tell whoever it is
isn't that good of a shot because they
hit her somewhere that probably isn't
gonna be critical but I mean it's a
badass-looking little clip there if she
looks unbelievable that scowl on her
face continuing to shoot without
skipping a beat see another shot of the
cannon at sunset as she is finishing up
the narration the voice-over this is the
part where she says the truth is we
don't all deserve to make it and of
course the way that episode 1 was set up
we learned that at some point she's
gonna turn from killing humans to
killing some of the hosts and that just
seems to be foreshadowing against that
she's gonna have to call some of the
members out for what they're going to do
I don't know at some point they all end
up in the lake so this is all on the way
to that happening but we don't really
know what's going on and then the whole
thing wraps up with a shot of a tiger is
this the tiger that they saw along the
bank of the water I would definitely
think so although there's nothing to say
whether this tiger in this shot is in
Westworld
or in what is probably raj world if you
guys were following theories and
spoilers and stuff someone caught that
from the west-world site that it looked
like it said raj world we know that
there's at least six parks we know that
one is Shogun world we know that one is
West world we believe that we will see
medieval world and Roman world but
Bengal tigers are from India and Raj
world seems to be about in the
so that seems to be a connection and why
we end the trailer with a tiger is
because Tigers are cool I guess and it's
going to play a part in the next episode
I'm interested to hear what you guys
think about this teaser there's not all
that much that's unpredictable I guess
what I'm most excited about here is
Bernard and Dolores meeting up I'm kind
of hoping that this episode revolves
more around Bernard I really am NOT
I mean I'll talk about this in the in
the recap for episode 2 but Dolores is
story right now is kind of the low point
for me I don't know why but I just I'm
not feeling it the Bernard story and the
mave story seem to be the most
interesting out of what we got going on
we saw no Bernard in Episode two so I
hope you get a lot more of him in
Episode three but yes I'm looking
forward to seeing what's going on with
that I'm looking forward to seeing what
this tiger is all about where is made
exactly when she sees that snow falling
is that Shogun world will we see that a
little bit earlier than what's
anticipated there are a few things that
we didn't see yet from the trailer that
was out last week we did not see her
even though this episode was the
previous episode was called reunion we
did not see her reunited with her child
that's coming up we saw that in the
trailer and obviously we know that she's
going to be there we saw her looking
like a Shogun with a pretty cool clip in
that trailer as well so yeah like I was
saying I think that as more and more
stuff comes to light I think it's pretty
clear that Ford knew what was going to
happen after he died and he actually set
it up I mean we know that he had this
thing for a bill the man in black to
follow a game to play we know that he
had access to Dolores and her memories
and what she's working with now and
obviously back in the past bill showed
Dolores something that she's after I do
sort of think the man in black is going
to change sides a bit this season I
don't think he'll be completely a bad
guy how that develops where that goes is
going to be kind of interesting I think
Delos themselves has been set up as the
guys and even though he's in charge on
some level he is obviously doing his own
thing he's not really looking out for
their interests so there's some room for
some interesting stuff to happen there I
really don't think what we're going to
see is gonna be very linear from this
point it could do that I could happen I
think they have more backstory to fill
in with young William and I think that
there is going to be a lot of unreliable
stuff we get from Bernard after they set
up that list of symptoms that he'll be
facing as he's fighting this critical
failure that he's been you know he gets
through it somehow or other because we
see him two weeks later but I think
there's a roller coaster ride in store
for him and we'll see a whole lot more
that so let me know what you guys are
looking forward to this season and this
episode as mentioned my time is really
tight right now like I really don't have
time to do YouTube I'm going to do the
best that I can and I'm going to do a
episode to recap I definitely won't have
time to go back to the first episode and
then I'll do it like this I'll do a
trailer breakdown first right after the
episode airs and the trailer comes out
and then I will do a recap a review
later in the week whenever I have time
to get it out so thanks for watching
please subscribe to my channel you can
check out my patreon although things are
pretty slow over there now if we could
get that going then I could take away
some time for my other work and focus
more but it just hasn't played out that
way so far you can follow me on Twitter
to see what my new videos are coming out
and it was great to have you I'm excited
to be back making videos even if it's
only part-time and I will be talking to
you again soon thanks